Taylor Swift is celebrating pride month
by pandering to the LGBT elementop Mafia
the Gestapo if you will and that of
course is not surprising what is
surprising
is that Taylor's message is accidentally
correct
I wish that every place was safe and
beautiful for people in the lgbtq
community
because you know we can't talk about
Pride it's about talking about pain
they're they're right now and recently
and in the recent years there have been
so many harmful pieces of legislation
that have put people in the lgbtq and
queer community at risk
it's painful for everyone every Ally
every loved one every person in these
communities and that's why I'm always
posting
this is when the midterms are this is
when these these important key primaries
risk threat
risk
the suicide rate for transgender
identifying people is 41 the biggest
threat to trans identifying people by
far really the only threat statistically
is themselves and at a deeper level the
ideology that leads them to reject
reality and attempt in vain to live
according to
Taylor Swift is right that we can't talk
about Pride without talking about pain
the ideology of pride in all its forms
well beyond the sex stuff inevitably
leads to pain because Pride goes before
destruction and a haughty spirit before
a fall and everyone knows it the
transgender activists know it that's why
they're always screaming for the
affirmation of their
The Pride paraders jiggling in the
streets know it hence the frenzy
bullying
that all of a corporate American
everyone else Falls in line
it's so obvious even Taylor Swift knows
it too I'm Michael Knowles it's the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show got a great
testimony of a former transheiser Bush
executive on why companies like a b
inbev Bud Light all the rest of them are
going rainbow and specifically are going
trans we'll get to that in just a second
first though speaking of the pain of
pride
the story from Reuters I think this sums
it up
Reuters here is quoting the World Health
Organization
you know that very scientific very
credible not at all political just plays
it straight whatever the science says
that's what they promote that
organization
this is last year when monkey pox was
surging
monkey pox spread no reason to shun
Pride parades
an unusual spread of monkey pox does not
mean people should shun lgbtq plus Pride
parades this summer a World Health
Organization expert said on Monday
adding that it was important to show
support first of all an unusual spread
of monkey pox what's unusual about it
monkeypox spreads at gay orgies
it's true that it can spread in other
ways but practically speaking the way it
spreads is gay orgies that's how this
recent epidemic of monkeypox began
because of weird fetishistic gay orgies
in Belgium and Spain that's how it began
it is for all intents and purposes a gay
sexually transmitted disease and there
are going to be a bunch of political
activists who insist no it's not monkey
pox it's not a sexually transmitted
disease it can be spread in other ways
that's true HIV can be spread in other
ways too HIV can be spread by sharing
needles on the street but HIV
practically speaking is a gay sexually
transmitted disease the same is true of
monkey pox
why is it important to show support
well not for health purposes of course
but for ideological purposes they go on
the usually mild illness that can cause
flu-like symptoms and skin lesions is
disproportionately affected men who have
sex with men that's the new term Health
officials have stressed the disease can
be transmitted to anyone who has close
contacts such as skin to skin
with an infected person
a usually mild illness that can cause
flu-like symptoms
that sounds familiar to me hold on
there's a there's a usually mild illness
that can cause flu-like symptoms that is
spreading like an epidemic but in this
case people should just go out and not
worry about it at all now the last time
we had a usually mild illness that
causes flu-like symptoms we were told we
had to lock down the entire world for
three years
we were told that we couldn't go see our
grandparents dying in the hospital we
were told that we couldn't go to
funerals we couldn't go to school we
couldn't go to work we couldn't go to
church we couldn't we could go to the
pot dispensary
we could go to BLM riots but we couldn't
go to any couldn't go to any any of the
other things okay
monkey box seems a lot worse actually
than that last usually mild illness that
causes flu-like symptoms and that monkey
pox causes skin lesions and it's just
generally white grosser well why is the
who encouraging people to go out there
quote it's important that people who
want to go out and celebrate gay pride
lgbtq plus Pride to continue to go and
plan to do so says Andy seal strategies
advisor at who's Department of sexually
transmitted infections programs that's
what he said at a who social media
briefing why is that important it's
certainly not important to Public Health
if you wanted to protect public health
and stop the spread of monkey pox you
would shut down all the pride parades
why is it important it's important
because the who is not exclusively or
even primarily a health or scientific
organization it's a political
organization it's made up of political
apparatics who set public policy which
is what conservatives have been saying
from the beginning of the covid
lockdowns
but at that time we were told by all the
libs that that The Who and the CDC and
all the rest of these groups merely were
presenting the science I'm not political
I've never had any political opinion
publicly I'm just talking about the
science
but here we have who saying explicitly
forget about the science in this case
the ideology is more important than the
spread of this epidemic and I know there
will be a lot of people who say what
about covid where was this idea during
covet and the answer is
this was the exact same story during
covet this is exactly what they told us
don't forget there was that letter
signed by some 1200 Public Health
officials
who insisted that it was important to go
Riot for the George Floyd protests
because they claimed that white
supremacy is a public health emergency
that predates and exacerbates covid-19
they just made it up he said if you're a
normal person who lives in normal life
and you want to go do normal things you
have to stay locked up in your home but
if you're a leftist terrorist you need
to go out in the streets and burn things
down now that's good for public health
but you going to Granny's funeral that's
bad for public health it's the same
story
the libs always exempt themselves from
their own rules and furthermore
even the most over the top clearly
scientific program
any of these programs that are within
public policy that claim to be neutral
they can never be neutral
they're always within a political
context they always take part in
philosophical and often ideological
premises and
the trick that the libs play is they
tell us all ostensibly free citizens of
a self-governing republic that we're not
allowed to question their public
policies when they do something it's
always science and unassailable
when we do something it's always
politics it's not scientific at all and
they can always Trump us with their
dictators and apparatics in lab coats
now the political order is obviously a
little unstable when that sort of thing
happens you're going to want to check
out Birch gold right now text Knowles to
98 98 98 president Trump recently issued
a warning from his Mar-A-Lago home quote
our currency is crashing and will soon
no longer be the world's standard which
will be our greatest defeat frankly in
200 years there are three reasons the
central banks are dumping the US dollar
inflation deficit spending and our
insurmountable national debt the fact is
there is one asset that is withstood
famine Wars and political and economic
upheaval dating back to ancient times
gold you can own gold in a tax sheltered
retirement account with the help of
Birch gold that is right Birch gold will
help you convert an existing Ira or 401K
maybe from a previous employer into an
IRA in Gold best part is you don't pay a
penny out of pocket text Knowles kwles
to 9898 98 for your free info kit they
will hold your hand through the entire
process think about this when currencies
fail gold is a safe haven how much more
time does the Dollar have protect your
savings with gold today Birch gold has
an A plus rating with a Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers text
Knowles to 98 98.98 to get your free
info kit on gold that is Knowles kwles
to 98 98 98
liberalism always protects itself
who does liberalism have to protect
itself from liberalism has to protect
itself from the people
liberalism and democracy we've seen this
increasingly in recent years or in
opposition to one another
and so what the liberals do is they
redefine democracy as liberalism
so when the majority of the people
oppose liberalism we're told that's a
threat to democracy even though that's a
completely incoherent statement
the majority of hungarians have elected
Victor Orban this poses a great threat
to democracy
the majority of Americans or American
electors have elected Donald Trump this
poses a great threat to democracy now of
course by definition the majority of
people voting for something can't pose a
threat to democracy but they just mean
liberalism and liberalism is an elite
ideology that looks on the people with a
great deal of skepticism
and tries to suppress the desires of the
people and liberalism is a revolutionary
ideology so liberalism's aims get
increasingly crazy we've seen this
within our own lifetimes we've seen this
within the last decade or two
liberalism which begins from the
starting point of
skepticism hey we can't really know
what's good hey we can't really know
what's true so you do you I'll do me
we're not going to harm each other we're
not going to interfere in each other's
lives we're just going to do our own
thing okay we're individuals we've got
our own views of the world and we're
just going to respect each other's views
okay that's how it starts relatively
modest way to begin
and then that becomes hey we can't
really know what marriage is
I know it's the fundamental political
institution but maybe it means one thing
for you and one thing for me who's to
say we'll just redefine it to mean
pretty much whatever we want it to mean
hey who's to say what a man is and what
a woman is we can you can't know your
view of man might not be my view of man
so we're going to let hulking dudes into
the women's locker room
hey we you know look all this religion
stuff man
that's really harsh in my mellow you
know it's really harsh in My Vibe man so
we got to kick the Bible out of schools
we got to kick prayer out of schools
we got to kick all public religion out
of the Public Square I mean not our
religion we're going to put our pride
Flags everywhere but your stuff like a
nativity scene at Christmas yeah we're
gonna get that out of the Public Square
now this is in opposition to what the
people want the vast majority of the
American people don't support
transgenderism
vast majority of the American people
don't support the weird rainbow Pride
progress flag everywhere the vast
majority of the American people don't
support any of this nonsense
and yet it continues to advance how
because liberalism has
little tricks up its sleeve one of which
is the judges the judges very often will
overrule the wise conservative impulses
of the people you're seeing this right
now in Tennessee federal judge
ruled on Friday that a Tennessee law
that Shields children from sexually
explicit performances is
unconstitutional Tennessee passed a law
which said hey if you're going to go
jiggle around in provocative sexual ways
if you're gonna have weird drag queens
flaunting their goods in front of kids
it's really flaunting their bads in
front of kids uh that's illegal you're
not allowed to do that okay pretty
reasonable right we don't want our kids
to be groomed by these weirdos and then
a federal judge comes in U.S District
Judge Thomas Parker
and says that this is
unconstitutionally vague and
substantially over Broad
but you meant unconstitutionally they
substantially overbroad don't groom the
kids don't take them to weird sex shows
that's unconstitutional can you imagine
James Madison rolling over in his grave
at this absolutely debauched Federal
judge's ruling Thomas Parker whoa when
you really think about it actually
when you really think of it don't you
think Thomas Jefferson
woke up in the morning with the stated
goal fought the revolution
to sexualize the little kids I don't
think so but that's what the
Revolutionary liberals want and when the
people say no and the people through
their representatives pass laws against
it the Revolutionary Libs come in
through the courts or wherever else and
they say nope too bad this same thing
happened with porn laws in the 90s
porn is one of the the big social
pathologies today it's ubiquitous it's
leading people into all sorts of
problems people right into the show
about this they say born is really
messed up my view of the world I was
exposed when I was 10 years old it's
really messed up my relationships causes
divorce it causes all sorts of problems
it causes people to take a really
violent abusive narcissistic view of
each other and the other sex and all of
it it's just it's just Dreadful so in
the 90s people saw this coming both
Democrats and Republicans and they tried
to do something about it they passed the
communications decency act which we now
talk about mostly in the context of big
Tech regulation but the communications
decency Act was really about decency in
Communications
they also passed the child online
protection act Coppa
this was passed under the Clinton
administration
which had a republican Congress this was
passed by both parties
is that we got to regulate porn on the
internet and then the the key provisions
of those laws were struck down by judges
who said nope liberalism demands that we
have porn everywhere and so we're going
to strike down
your censorship of it
even though your censorship of it is
perfectly in line with the American
tradition the vast majority of the
American people want it too bad we're
going to strike it down liberalism
protects itself and so the revolution
goes marching on no matter what the
people of either party try to do about
it
you're seeing this reach a fever pitch
down in Utah right now A Utah School
District
a Utah School District at a time when
we cannot ban
gay porn from Elementary School
classrooms and libraries in many cases
at a time when we cannot pass laws
prohibiting perverts from jiggling
around for little kids
Utah
Utah's Davis School District has just
banned the LA the Bible rather from its
libraries and classrooms for vulgarity
and violence
this is this is really clever
School District said that the Bible
could be considered pornographic this
after a parent filed a complaint and so
Elementary Middle School students in
Utah's Davis School District north of
Salt Lake City will no longer be able to
find the Bible at school libraries now
of course the Bible already could not be
taught in schools because some liberals
on the Supreme Court just decided that
out of thin air in the middle of the
20th century now it won't even be found
in the libraries
the book will remain in circulation
quote only at the high school level
based on age-appropriateness due to
vulgarity or violence that according to
school district spokesman Christopher
Williams and NBC News
why now the parent is filing the
complaint because this parent is upset
that conservatives are Banning actual
gay porn like genderqueer by Maya kababi
graphic visual depictions of of
disturbing sex
and disordered sex
being presented for little kids
because that is now being kicked out of
some schools this parent says well we're
going to kick the Bible out of schools
what's the complaint say
the complaint says
incest onanism bestiality prostitution
genital mutilation fellatio dildos rape
and even infanticide
you'll no doubt find that in the Bible
under Utah code section 76 blah blah
blah the Bible has quote no serious
values for minors because it's
pornographic by our new definition
that's what they're saying see I got you
got your conservatives
tell me that the Bible doesn't include
descriptions of those things or at least
allusions to all those things it does
you're right
the Bible
alludes to incest onanism that's where
we get the word for onanism
if you don't know what it is don't look
it up
bestiality yeah okay fine it alludes to
all these things
this is why the current milk toast
conservative approach to this issue is
not going to work the current milk toast
conservative approach the kind of
squishy Hey listen I'm being reasonable
here I don't want to go after the pride
people I'm just I'm just totally um I'm
just neutral on this issue forget it we
don't need to ban gay sex from or gay
porn from elementary schools we want to
ban all sexual teaching that's the
current kind of milk toast view but that
will never work
you actually Can't Ban all teaching that
in any way alludes to sex from
elementary school because
sex including and especially the sexual
distinction between men and women is
fundamental to human nature if you if
you teach a book to elementary school
students about
Mr John and Mrs Jane and their dog spot
and their son jack
you are teaching something about sex
you're teaching something about family
and how men and women relate to one
another and what family looks like you
are teaching something about sex
when you teach the Bible
there are plenty of references in the
Bible to all of these sorts of
unpleasant things
the question is not what do these books
allude to
but what do the books teach about those
things
yes the Bible references incest only as
in bestiality prostitution General
mutilation the list goes on and on and
on
and the Bible says those things are bad
and the pride people also teach about
all of these things
onanism
fellatio infanticide obviously
all these weird weird sex things
and the The Pride people say that those
things are good
and a value-neutral approach to
education is not going to be able to
discern between the two things
which means that a value neutral
approach to education is just going to
be exploited by The leftists Who know
what their values are and who are
willing to enforce their values in
Public Square to to install gay porn in
elementary schools and to kick out the
Bible the only coherent response to that
is going for us is going to be for us to
stop pushing this value neutral nonsense
which can never exist in practice and to
say hey yeah you're right the Bible and
Maya kababi both teach about these
things but one of them says they're bad
one of them says they're good and we
know that these are bad things and so
we're going to teach kids that they're
bad things we're going to teach kids
that men can't become women and we're
going to teach kids that the way you
have a family is mommy Mary's Daddy and
they have a child together and we're and
the family is a basic building block of
society and it's good to do that and
it's good to be fruitful and multiply
and it's bad to do all this like weird
sex stuff that the libs are trying to
teach five-year-olds yeah we're gonna
have values
it's either going to be ours or it's
going to be theirs
which view do you want to teach
genderqueer or Genesis Exodus and
Deuteronomy you tell me Utah I know
which one I want to teach
I think Utah and the rest of the country
needs to get a little bit more serious
about it
we're in a place right now where the
country is is really quite unstable I've
mentioned it many times and that's why
you got to check out my Patriot Supply
right now go to
preparewithknolls.com I love that URL in
a world filled with uncertainties it is
crucial to be ready for whatever comes
your way whether it's a natural disaster
a sudden emergency or unforeseen
circumstances having a reliable food
storage system can provide you with
peace of mind and the assurance that you
and your loved ones will be well taken
care of right now my Patriot Supply is
knocking 200 off their popular
three-month emergency food kit to help
you start growing your supply go to
preparewithknolls.com grab this special
price before it ends your three-month
emergency food kit provides over 2 000
calories each day for optimal strength
and energy in stressful situations you
can enjoy a wide variety of my Patriot
Supply food from buttermilk pancakes and
chicken alfredo to rice pudding their
meals have you covered for every part of
your day best part is each meal is
delicious don't wait for disaster to
strike before taking action invest in
your safety and well-being by securing
your food storage today go to
preparewithknolls.com save 200 on each
kit your family needs prepare with
knowles.com right now that is prepare
with knowles.com
speaking of Education Minnesota's just
announced it will give free college
education to illegal aliens
this is being tatted as a way to quote
provide historic investment for student
support and our institutions they're
going to be a lot of people who have
paid for College in Minnesota who are
going to be furious about this people
who are American citizens Minnesota
taxpayers they had to pay for their
education meanwhile these illegal aliens
come in they break our laws and they get
free education this isn't fair yeah
you're right it's not fair why would the
state do this the state would do this
because education
public education is not primarily about
the individual public education is
primarily about the state
the state of Minnesota a liberal people
who rule Minnesota
are not doing this because they really
care for the well-being of the
Venezuelan migrants or I guess more
likely Somalian migrants into Minnesota
the liberal rulers of Minnesota are
doing this because they know that
forcing these people into classrooms
will shape their minds and and impel
them to conform to the liberal ideology
that governs the state
that's what education is for Education
just means bringing somebody up raising
somebody teaching somebody
that's why we have to do it inevitably
you need to be educated you're going to
be educated one way or the other
now previously we had a little bit of a
mixture of Education in our country
for a long time it was just private
education various forms of private and
very local education then the liberal
reformers came in and they imposed ever
more National forms of public education
and then they started to extend the time
timeline on it so it used to be
you'd go to public education first grade
through
eighth grade and then later on 12th
grade okay first through 12th that's
great
then they added kindergarten onto that
then they added preschool onto that
then they started to insist upon college
for everybody so all of a sudden the 12
years that you were going to spend in
public education which was going to be
offset by all the time you were spending
at home those Summers with your family
the time you're spending in church the
time you're spending in your community
all of a sudden all that extra time with
all those other influences starts to get
crowded out and it's crowded out by the
liberal state which is going to spend
more and more time influencing you from
preschool starting at age three these
days I know some people who send their
kids to preschool which is
really just daycare but it's daycare
with an ideological bent to it they'll
start doing that at age two
and then now everyone has this view that
they have to go to college then you had
another four years on the end of that
and then some people
who can barely spell their names frankly
are going on and getting master's
degrees and try to get a PhD still
requires a fair bit of sophistication
but to get a master's degree that's been
watered down greatly
and it's too bad for the people who
actually are seeking a further higher
education because the quality of the
education at virtually every level has
been watered down it's been watered down
intentionally by the state which is just
seeking to bring as many people into the
system as it possibly can
of course the rulers in Minnesota are
going to do this it benefits them
politically speaking of people up north
Canada
as a new
Public Health campaign Canada's Public
Health campaign
will be to print warnings on cigarettes
now we've had warnings on cigarettes for
many decades at this point and if you
ever travel to Europe you'll know that
the warnings get even more intense here
it just says Surgeon General was warning
cigarettes are bad for you they can
cause cancer or they can cause birth
defects okay when you go to Europe it's
just these big letters of smoking kills
quit smoking now it's it's all sorts of
diseased organs it's jokes about
erectile dysfunction it's really intense
and in your face Canada is now going
further
as Canada seems to go further on
everything
the nicest people in the world seem to
go extremely to the extremes of
offensiveness and absurdity
more than anyone else on Earth and yet
they're so nice about it they're like oh
well you know wait hey don't you know
we're gonna go kill all the elderly and
the homeless people yes don't you know
so Canada has decided they're going to
print the warnings not just on the
cigarette cartons not just on cigarette
packs on the cigarettes themselves which
is really genius right you've already
you got the tobacco and you got all the
added chemicals that the cigarette
companies put in and now Canada is going
to add ink to that as well that's
probably healthy for you right and
Canada has announced that they're going
to put them on all the cigarettes
first country in the world to do so
they're hoping other countries follow
suit my question is
and Canada going to do the same thing
for doobies
is Canada going to require warning
labels on big fat blunts is that the
next step no
no Canada is not going to do that
even though marijuana
is in many ways much worse for you than
cigarettes
will leave your lungs filled with more
tar than cigarettes will
that doesn't matter Canada has legal
marijuana not just for medical purposes
but for recreation too the Liberals in
Canada are all fine with you filling
your lungs with very toxic mind-altering
smoke
when it's the smoke that they like just
not the smoke that we like tobacco
broadly is preferred by conservatives we
like
cigars we like dip
we like
even cigarettes people who smoke
cigarettes tend to be of the working
class and so
while it's true that many of them might
vote Democrat the working classes
broadly tend to be
temperamentally
conservative ins constitutionally
conservative
they're not the radical activists out
there they're the kind of normal people
who like their norms and customs
that's who likes tobacco broadly
speaking the conservative people who
likes doobies I know that they're right
Wingers who like to smoke the devil's
lettuce puff on a few Jazz cigarettes
every now and again spark up the
Peruvian parsley but broadly speaking
the people who like
marijuana are the libs it's a lib thing
okay and so in Canada
you got two substances that you could
smoke one of which actually is worse for
you and it's marijuana
the marijuana no warning label it's fine
go do it it's great peace and love man
it's wonder drug it cures everything
tobacco which sharpens your mind makes
you quicker if it does anything at all
uh in addition to all the health
concerns the way it affects your mind is
it just makes you smarter and faster
that's the one that needs the warning
label
this is just a matter of imposing
political preference and culture on
people and ideology we're gonna we're
going to punish the conservative thing
we're going to support the liberal thing
this is why during covid the libs locked
down the churches they kept the pot
dispensaries open
this is why
the reason why is that they're going to
punish the conservative thing they're
going to reward and encourage the
liberal thing the libs view politics
as little more than a distinction
between friends and enemies
you're seeing this now in some of what's
coming to life from covid the new CDC
director woman named Mandy Cohen just
recounted how she as then North Carolina
Health director
came up with her covid mandates
I would call probably the person I
called most was the Secretary of Health
and Human Services in Massachusetts she
worked for Republican Governor just to
um but you know when she was like are
you are you going to let them have
professionals
um uh football and I was like nope and
she's like okay neither are we neither
way uh
um so uh you know it was like
conversations like that so or or I'd be
like so when are you gonna think about
lightening up a mess or like you're like
next Monday I'm like okay next Monday
just a couple girls Gavin you know hey
hey Shirley
are you gonna let are you gonna let your
guys go to their grandparents funerals
nah okay yeah I didn't know I was sort
of like just flip a coin I don't know
so
how was your day what do you think
this was just a couple of girls gabbing
this was not the inerrant infallible
voice of science with a capital s
this is politics not science hey you
think we can get away with this nah okay
we won't push that hard
what about this yeah we could probably
do that we probably can't shut down
these BLM riots right and anyway it's
really important they go out there and
they Riot but we can stop the
conservatives from going to church can't
yeah okay good okay we'll do that that's
good
hey
do you think we should uh tell the the
orgy people to stop doing the orgy stuff
because monkey pox is spreading a lot
no we like Pride yay Pride okay that's
fine forget about that one but we'll
tell the conservatives that they have to
shut down their businesses right yeah
okay good
politics not science of course which
frankly
is how it should be
Dr fauci was always wrong and he was
always a liar maybe he was just totally
ignorant of of what politics and science
are I don't I don't put just total
benighted ignorance past the man
but public policy is always about
politics and trade-offs and what kind of
society we want to live in when the libs
say look it's more important to us that
we have the big rainbow parades than
that we stop the spread of monkey pox
that's a legitimate political position
to hold it's not a very smart one but
it's a legitimate political position to
hold you're saying we want a cultural
and sexual Revolution more than we want
to stop people from Catching this STD
when when the the libs came out and they
said we support the BLM riots
even though it'll spread covid we
support the BLM rights it's more
important that the libs go out and burn
down the the buildings and loot the Nike
stores then that we stop the spread of
this flu-like disease that's a
legitimate political position to hold
the problem is we were told that it
wasn't political we were told that we're
not allowed to have political views
ourselves and we're not we're not
allowed to support them
this is this is an admission of what the
conservatives knew the whole time and
it's a return to something that's more
normal and more basic which is
self-government now science
for all of its flaws you know I'm very
skeptical of science
skeptical not just of scientism and the
lab coat people and those who have
perverted science I'm skeptical of
basically the entire scientific project
I'm skeptical of the way of thinking
that has characterized the Western mind
since the Scientific Revolution I'm
skeptical of arguments about what a
woman is let's say that that merely boil
down to two X chromosomes in a uterus I
just think that's reductive and soul
denying and and ignores the metaphysical
basis of reality so I'm kind of down on
science but there's some good stuff that
comes out of scientific and
technological advancement
one piece of evidence for this would be
the baby boxes and specifically a baby
box in Knoxville have you heard of baby
boxes baby boxes are exactly what they
sound like
it's a safe haven box
where
mothers
who choose not to kill their children
through abortion who choose to give
birth to children but don't know what to
do with them once the children are born
they can just drop the baby off usually
at a firehouse or or police station
put the baby in a box and the baby will
then be put up for adoption
we'll go into a sort of orphanage foster
care system but then hopefully be put up
for adoption
um this used to happen people would
leave
babies at the fire department
but the babies could die of exposure I
mean this has happened before abandoned
babies will die of exposure very quickly
these are these are very vulnerable
creatures so the baby box was invented
to be climate controlled to be very safe
to give First Responders an opportunity
to come and help the babies out this has
now been used in Knoxville
Tennessee's first Safe Haven baby box
was used for the first time this was
about a couple of weeks ago
according to the Knoxville fire
department and the baby was
approximately 30 minutes old
firefighters called an ambulance they
took the baby to the hospital the baby
is doing very well great stuff reminder
that conservatives cannot totally turn
our back on technology I don't really
like modern technology at all I'm not a
big fan of having screens everywhere or
any I basically never texted anybody
back I I'm not but
this is a great example of saying as
technology advances let's turn it to our
own good while the libs are turning
technology toward creating babies and
Laboratories and in insisting upon these
designer baby Eugenics campaigns that
are ghoulish and anti-human well well
the libs are turning the technology
toward killing babies the conservatives
are going to turn that technology toward
saving babies who are in danger and that
is great news now I mentioned this
question of what is a woman
you might have seen this phrase in the
news the last couple of days
daily wire we just had the fight of our
lives and we won yet again
we won
it was the beginning of pride month and
the one year anniversary of Matt's
groundbreaking documentary what is a
woman so we decide to celebrate by
making it free for everyone to watch on
Twitter for a day or two we all thought
that Twitter 1.0 was coming back from
the ashes with the censorship and the
suppression of conservative voices when
that movie was marked hateful conduct
for misgendering well the great news is
Elon Musk made good on his promise not
only did he remove the restrictions but
he personally tweeted out the movie said
every parent should watch it it was a
huge victory for the message of the film
the Tweet now has over 170 million views
has made headlines around the world for
the second pride month in a row it was
the number one streaming movie on Rotten
Tomatoes of all films in all categories
it's gotten more views than CNN MSNBC
and Fox News combined daily wire
I'll say it I want to tutor ironhorn too
much it's a culture changing engine no
other conservative Media Company can say
that we owe a debt of gratitude to those
of you who have supported our mission we
wouldn't have been able to do it without
you and for those of you who saw what as
a woman for the first time this weekend
this kind of content is what we do best
there's a lot more to come there's still
a lot of work to be done we have to keep
pushing back against the libs we have to
shine some light into that Darkness so
thank you to those of you who have
joined and if you haven't sign up what
are you waiting for now is the time
because if you sign up today you'll get
25 off your membership when you use code
woman at checkout go to dailywear.com
subscribe today my favorite comment on
Fridays from Old School
love old school he keeps cropping up in
the comments who says
congratulations to Joe Biden for being
the most down-to-earth president of all
time
down to earth do you get it
do you get it
that was a good one it was a really good
one
the liberal system
is designed to advance this radicalism
it's not just one company it's not just
one guy it's the whole
system as a former executive for
transheiser Bush explained just a couple
of days ago
so how does this actually work these
guys are telling the truth here's how it
works it's pretty simple you just have
to follow the money if you take a look
at BlackRock State Street Vanguard they
managed 20 trillion dollars worth of
capital but it's not their own money
this is the money that everyday citizens
firefighters police officers doctors who
generally have their money either via
401ks or in a lot of cases large Pension
funds large Pension funds like the state
of California which manages the largest
pension fund in the U.S in the state of
New York and the European European
Pension funds as well and a lot of the
politicians in those States in
California for example they recently
have mandated those large Pension funds
that they divest from things like fossil
fuels in oil and gas and then when when
Bill de Blasio mayor of New York was
there did the same thing but they also
sell BlackRock State Street and Vanguard
if they're going to manage their money
they have to commit to things like ESG
diversity Equity inclusion and adopt
firm-wide commitments that they
therefore then Force onto all the major
companies in Corporate America
so obviously this guy Anson Fredericks
knows what he's talking about and Anson
is also one of the founders of strive
Asset Management which is Vivek
ramaswamis
asset management company to
fight against woke investment what he's
describing this ESG movement is this
idea that the asset managers were able
to use your money to throw your weight
around for the for their ideological
celebrated causes and then Force the
corporations to get in line
very true and as this issue becomes more
prominent which it will over the next
year that's going to be very good for
vivek's presidential campaign
because everyone's looking for a lane
Trump is Trump he's running the Trump
Lane
populism
old right
old conservative kind of Lane
correcting a lot of the
ideological preferences on the right of
the last 23 years Ron DeSantis is
running in that same Lane he's just
running on an efficiency competency
platform
so he's saying I'm going to do all the
Trump stuff but I'm going to be better
at it I'm going to get it done in a way
that Trump was not able to get it done
and I'm going to win in a way that
Trump's not going to be able to win okay
that's that's where they're running
you've got Nikki Haley Tim Scott very
likely Mike Pence running in the same
Lane the sort of moderate acceptable
Centrist appeal to Suburban Housewives
kind of Lane
and then you've got the Vegas running in
this out of left field ESG Lane he's
running on the woke Incorporated stop
the woke takeover of corporate America
line that's that's an issue that is kind
of unique to him uh this is good this is
good news for his presidential
campaign
now it's a system I've said it's a
system one great evidence of this it was
the most egregious reporting I've seen
in weeks and it has to do with what is a
woman
NBC News
NBC News tweets out
on Thursday Twitter was roiled by an
organized pressure campaign by
conservative pundits seeking to promote
a 95-minute anti-transgender video
the incident resulted in two high-level
departures within 24 hours
this is a really amazing example
of rhetoric and dishonesty in rhetoric
a 95-minute anti-transgender video
is there a word
for 90 minute videos do we have another
word in our language for videos that are
an hour and a half long oh we usually
call them movies or films it's a
95-minute anti-transgender video makes
you think it's shot on an iPhone or
something and it's this kind of weird
bizarre rant what does a woman is a
multi-million dollar movie it's the most
popular movie of the year and one of the
most popular documentaries of all time
oh it's just a 95-minute
anti-transgender video it was an
organized pressure campaign by
conservative pundits they're referring
it there I assume to the Twitter spaces
that that kicked off this controversy
and that was Twitter a Twitter spaces
that was run by
Jeremy Ben me Matt Drew Jordan Peterson
Candace Owens oh it's just some
conservative pundits no it's the head of
one of the biggest media companies on
the right
one of the most
prominent media companies these days in
the country Jordan Peterson the most
prominent public intellectual in the
world it's true some of us are
conservative pundits but you know it's
not just people mouthing off on Tick
Tock exactly okay this is a little bit
more of an organized serious
institutionalized kind of uh situation
that we're talking about here
they say oh no it's just it's all all On
The Fringe this is what the libs always
do they say all your views your your
views ordinary Americans they're they're
very fringy they're out of the
mainstream the fact that these people
have the audacity to call themselves
mainstream media is so is hilarious it's
risible
Main Street if you think that marriage
is what it has always been for all of
human history you know involves
men and women sexual difference oh
you're friends you're crazy if you think
men can't become women you're friends
you're crazy now
oh you're just one of these weirdo
little pundits with a long video
that Royal Twitter well it worked
why did it work because the vast
majority of people know that we're right
and we do now have
the richest man in the world who's who
is standing up for free speech and for
the truth in this case
the headline of the NBC article
musk's response to an anti-trans video
Sparks 24 hours of chaos at Twitter
24 hours of Chaos
chaos no it just caused some like Libs
to quit basically right that was it
and then Elon promoted the video okay
great
you you see this all over this pressure
campaign
this is a story near and dear to my
heart
I spoke at the University of Buffalo a
few months ago
there were lots of protests and all
sorts of nonsense I was I was condemned
by not only the administration of the
school I was condemned by the chancellor
of Sunni the entire State University of
New York System why for this issue
because I said men and women are
different because I said that for the
good of society and especially for the
good of the poor people who've Fallen
prey to this
and
transgenderism must be eradicated from
from public life entirely the whole
ideology at every level you know that
there was that little little controversy
so as a result of that the U Buffalo was
forced to allow me to speak because it's
a publicly funded institution and I've
First Amendment right and the students
at the school have First Amendment
rights well now you Buffalo has decided
to cancel the entire Young American
Young Americans Foundation chapter
because they invited me to speak that
they used a bunch of little uh
procedural loopholes to ban this group
of students from campus from meeting on
campus and from operating as a student
group because
they had the temerity to invite
me a conservative speaker to come speak
there so they're suing
yaph is suing and they've got ADF the
alliance defending Freedom uh helping
them with that lawsuit which is really
really great news
the libs view Politics As a matter of
friends and enemies
if you're their friend you can get away
with anything if you're their enemy
nothing you do can ever be right you
will be destroyed This Is How They view
things
there's no mainstream there's no
neutrality there's no meeting in the
middle on these sorts of issues
either we're going to win or we're going
to lose right now we're winning well we
need some more backbone we need some
more Clear Vision
we need some more support to keep on
winning you know it's music Monday Baby
the rest of the show continues now you
don't want to miss it because we started
the show with Taylor Swift and
coincidentally providentially Mr Davies
has given us a new Taylor Swift song
to to
analyze to critique
to parse and understand this song's been
up for nine days it's already got 14
million views these Taylor Swift I don't
know why
is pretty much the most popular person
on planet Earth I couldn't tell you a
Taylor Swift song I don't think I've
ever consciously intended to listen to a
Taylor Swift song
and yet everyone absolutely loves her so
we'll get to that daily wire.com Knowles
use code and also check out for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]